sacred geometry is the study of all the
patterns that exist because there's a
pattern to everything
and the key to empowerment is
understanding what the pattern is of
that thing whether it's our finances
whether it's our relationships whether
it's our health there's always a pattern
behind success or failure and in the
ancient world they understood that these
patterns also exist for understanding
who am I why am I here what is the
purpose of this current Incarnation what
is the purpose of us incarnating into a
physical body in a physical world to
begin with as a kid I never understood
why people focus their attention on such
transient things and didn't ask the most
basic question about who am I and why am
I here and how do we use this current
incarnation in the best way before it's
all over
ancient Egyptian temple science was a
qualitative science today when we think
about science we think about it being
quantitative but in the ancient world
they understood things in terms of
qualities of energy so there's an
energetic aspect that comes from higher
spiritual Realms higher spiritual planes
to create this world that gets expressed
in the powers of color and shape and
angle and proportion and number
sequences all these things are a kind of
divine code or Divine language of this
world in the ancient world in every
ancient tradition including ancient
Egypt they had systems of initiation
where people went through certain
step-by-step processes that would expand
their Consciousness to higher levels so
they would begin to perceive themselves
as a multi-dimensional being operating
on multiple planes at the same time they
would begin to understand the way that
human consciousness can be developed
much much further than it is currently
to develop abilities that we tend to
think of today as magical and the human
Energy System can be developed much much
further
and to do things that again today would
be thought to be impossible in working
with natural forces
and so it kind of comes back I can
paraphrase the work of Arthur C Clarke
who he says any sufficiently advanced
form of technology that one does not
understand will appear to be magic
and that's very much the way it was in
ancient Egypt and these other ancient
cultures they thought about things in a
completely different way than we do and
that makes if you see things from a
different perspective it makes things
that seem to be impossible possible we
need to understand some of the
fundamentals of what spiritual
initiation really is yeah so one aspect
of this has been almost forgotten today
is that when we do anything with our
Consciousness or our energy it starts to
create an energy pattern in our physical
body and our energy field
so whatever thoughts we keep generating
whatever their quality is
whatever energies we're generating with
our heart or with our actions in the
world
it's developing a pattern that then
creates a type of secret geometric
structure in our energy field
and so for advanced
masters of this work they could check
out somebody's field and see what energy
structures are present so this is a very
simple way to explain that certain
chakras in their energy field would be
more activated or not very activated or
they would be balanced in a harmonious
way or they would be unbalanced or the
energy meridians and patterns in the
body would be fully open or they would
be blocked all of these things are
components of larger geometric patterns
that can be created in the human energy
field
and so this development of the
Consciousness and energy gets reflected
in energy patterns in a person's field
and that's the pearl of great price that
we can take through the gate of death
and then into a new rebirth and this is
a classic idea but this is like the
thing that really matters like we can
just while away our time here and not
have it add up to much of anything and
we're no more advanced at the time of
death than we were when we came here in
the first place or we can do some really
serious development work with our
Consciousness and energy and become more
than we were before and again that gets
preserved in these energy patterns in
our field that's like the one thing you
take with you yeah so what's the
consequence of not improving in this
life so we can quickly hook more people
to listen
so that they understand how they can fix
their energy field and make progress and
improve the patterns of their life or
whatever those things are that we're
gonna you're gonna help us understand
there are many consequences but probably
the most fundamental thing that that'll
drive it home for everybody is that if
you do not use this lifetime for
advancing your state and you don't
understand the patterns of life then
basically you're just going to be
condemned to keep repeating the same
mistakes and you're going to repeat
yourself to an endless cycle of
suffering so that's one of the main
Concepts in Buddhism is how much
unnecessary suffering are we exposing
ourselves to by not striving for
enlightenment or not doing the basic
work to be able to observe and control
our mind to observe and control and
direct our feeling life to observe and
control our energy and our actions in
the world to control and direct our
speech
so this is really a universal concept
but for the Buddhists they talk about
skillful action take skillful action
you'll develop yourself to a place where
you have more pleasure you have more
freedom you understand how things work
and you can make an educated decision or
you can take unskillful action just be
in the reactive mind and react
emotionally to everything around you in
a way that's destructive and destroys
relationships destroys possibilities and
then you'll just stay on that cycle of
suffering so that's really the most
fundamental part of it but the other
part of it is there's a deeper aspect of
suffering beyond our usual day-to-day
experience and that is there's a type of
subtle suffering that comes by not
knowing Who We Are by not remembering
who we are why we're here what we chose
to do in this Incarnation this larger
spiritual context it's often very
subconscious in people but it drives
them to try to fill their lives with
other things that just become
destructive in the end well help us get
off the wheel of karma I'll do I'll do
what I can I'm working to get off it
myself but yes
I mean well is that I mean as
right now is that innate within the
human existence is that we will never be
able to fully see ourselves and remember
our past and remember where we came from
and who we are and that is confined
within this Dimension as part of the
human existence in the in our in our in
our challenge of this reality is that
part of this Matrix this was understood
in the ancient world in classical
initiation as what was referred to
as taking the draft of forgetfulness
this means that when you incarnate you
are made to forget who you are where
you're from what this whole purpose is
your past incarnations the whole thing
sure do this classic understanding of
the draft of forgetfulness is the thing
that we come in not remembering now this
is not true for people of certain levels
of higher Spiritual Development because
of the structures they've created in
their subtle bodies they can bring in
the remembrance of who they are pretty
much from the beginning and these people
can recognize the people around them in
their lives from their connections with
them in previous lives and they they
maintain more of this knowledge but
that's based on certain structures you
create in the subtle body that takes
work it takes knowledge to to create
these now initiation one major part of
it has always been to go through a
remembering process in the European
rosicrucian tradition there's a great
initiation saying which is in the
beginning was the memory that means the
first thing that we have to do when we
come back every time is to regain our
karmic memory of who we are because this
is not our first rodeo we've done this
before and so there's certain types of
karmic exercises a person can do to
start to remember who they are where
they come from Etc and that that gate is
not as close for some people as it is
for others
and particularly there's a lot of this
going on now because there's been such a
Resurgence of what in the ancient world
was particular types of plant medicine
that were used in initiation processes
and is now coming back with the mass use
of psychotropics often related to the
old plant medicine and that can often
help people regain their karmic memory
through certain activations
but the key thing here is to remember
again who we are why we're here because
otherwise you know it's like we're in
some movie where we're amnesic and we
have to go through this whole process of
where am I what's happened what's this
whole thing about but once we start to
remember that now we regain our purpose
and we begin to remember who we've been
and how that's led to here and that this
is itself only one bead in a chain
leading to a particular destination for
us to become a unique spiritual being in
the world
it's what from the Greek work is called
teleological destination it's like we're
being pulled towards what we're meant to
become in the future and all these
interesting things happen to us people
we meet and experiences that were given
and things we didn't expect appearing in
our lives helping to pull us toward this
and so like again in the old rosicrucian
initiation this was referred to as
reading the name and scribed on the
stone
and this is where we begin to remember
who we've been before now there's a lot
of challenges with this because it's
very easy for this to fall into fantasy
where we're just projecting all types of
things about I'd like to be this I'd
like to be that so if people if their
first memories are something that's very
elevated like I was this fantastic
famous historical figure in the past and
I'm just drenched in glory then often
that should be questioned because when
you actually start doing past life
regression with people it's very common
that first thing they remember are
traumatic experiences being a scullery
made in 13th century France where you
were horribly abused this type of thing
but the larger aspect of it is that
there is a purpose to our series of
incarnations now again going to the
modern European rosicrucian tradition
which I believe is a kind of
transformation of the old Egyptian
initiation the essene initiation the
Greek the Holy Grail tradition in Europe
into a modern format
there's a whole aspect of this where
human race has a esoteric name just like
the higher Angelic beings have names
that that point to what their power
their function is the name for the human
race and the rosicrucian tradition is
that we are spirits of love and freedom
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen